which saw baddies then chills down our
spines and which fail to scare anyone
we're here to answer that question by
ranking the horror franchise's many
villains
from worst to best jigsaw is a divisive
film within the source series
and it goes in a very different
stylistic direction than its
predecessors
its addition to the series is also a
point of contention for fans
in terms of the series continuity which
had previously been fairly airtight
logan nelson is presented as a veteran
with ptsd
now serving as a police medical examiner
and a key suspect throughout the events
of jigsaw
while working at a hospital logan
accidentally mixes up john kramer's
x-rays with another patient
which leads to john's cancer going
untreated this error sees logan placed
in the trap that occurs before the
events of the first film
where he seemingly dies first however he
actually survives and jigsaw ultimately
decides he doesn't deserve to die over
an honest mistake
thus he makes logan his original
apprentice logan is even revealed as a
co-creator
of the original reverse bear trap game
from the first film
behind every great man is a woman and in
the case of john kramer
that woman is his former wife jill tuck
you are my heart you always have been
you always
will be jill stands out as the most
innocent person among these antagonists
she doesn't operate out of any sense of
vengeance or moral desire
but out of a sense of tying a blue sense
jill is formally introduced in sur4 as a
key part of jigsaw's backstory
we learned that jill and john separated
after the death of their unborn child
which is what leads jon to become the
jigsaw killer jill takes on a more major
role in saw 5
and saw 6 when she has bequeathed the
box as part of jon's will
the box contains a list of the next crop
of players and special instructions
which lead jill to put mark hoffman in
the reverse bear trap
which he unfortunately escapes the
tables are turned in saw seven when jill
is placed in the reverse bear trap
herself
which leads to her demise gordon crawls
off into the darkness of the conclusion
at the first saw film
leaving hardcore fans with the question
what the heck happens to him
don't don't worry i'll bring someone
back i promise
finally in saw seven it is revealed that
after escaping the bathroom
dr gordon had his wounds tended to by
jigsaw and was released
back into the world we go on to learn
that while jigsaw was grooming amanda
and huffman as tentative successors and
inheritors of his legacy
he also kept dr gordon around as an
extra set of hands to aid him in his
endeavors
gordon not only assisted with the more
medical traps of saw 2 and saw 4
he also helps jigsaw choose a surgeon
who operates on him in saw three
most importantly at the conclusion of
sauce 7 gordon kidnaps mark hoffman
and proceeds to lock him in the bathroom
from the first film
bringing everything full circle zepp
hindle serves as a creative red herring
in the first film
introduced as a mildly creepy orderly
working in dr gordon's hospital
zepp is heavily implied to be the jigsaw
killer the movie leads the audience to
believe this
in multiple ways including zep's
presence behind the security cameras
and the fact that he's the one who holds
dr gordon's family hostage
zeppa meets his ender adam's hands when
the latter bludgeons him with a toilet
tank lid
adam searches zep's pockets for some
kind of key to escape his shackles
only to find that step had his own tape
from jigsaw
and was merely a pawn in a larger game
mark hoffman is first introduced as a
cop assigned to the jigsaw investigation
in saw 3. he is later revealed to be
jigsaw's apprentice
mentally broken by the murder of his
sister hoffman engineers his own jigsaw
style death trap for the perpetrator in
the form of sore five's famous pendulum
trap
you know why you're here don't you
given his status as a police officer he
is able to throw everyone off his scent
everyone except for john cramer who
doesn't take too kindly to someone
jacking his style
especially in a way he deems to be
inappropriate
say what you will about kramer but at
least he gives his victims a chance to
win their game
hoffman didn't and that is what leads
kramer to take action
hoffman serves as the main antagonist
from saw four to saw seven
introduced as a victim in the original
saw amanda is a former drug addict
after she becomes one of the only people
to ever survive a jigsaw trap
john recruits her to help him carry out
his work
i found myself a father a leader
a teacher the key difference between the
two is that amanda doesn't see giving
people a fair chance
as necessary to the games in fact she
often injects her own agenda into her
creations
rendering her traps unwinnable a
definite no-no in john's eyes
during the events of saw three jon
engineers things to give amanda one
final chance
to do things the right way however
amanda acts impulsively coerced by
hoffman
and this leads to the demise of dr lynn
denlon amanda herself
and inadvertently jon it's very clear
that amanda wants to follow jon's
teachings to the letter
but her own demons and inability to
separate herself
emotionally from her work is what leads
to her downfall
it is legitimately sad to see her bleed
to death in front of jon
as he laments the fact that she couldn't
pass his test
john kramer has one of modern horrors
most compelling backstories
after enduring tragedy and illness he
becomes so detached from the world that
he dedicates the rest of his life to
making sure people cherish their lives
through the most heinous possible means
the morbidly ironic traps and games he
devises for his players
usually cause them to mutilate
themselves or others for the sake of
long-term survival
they are the series trademark and the
manifestation of jon's twisted ethos
when compared to the likes of freddy
krueger or jason voorhees
jon stands out he definitively dies in
saw three
yet still manages to be present and
active in the series
though other villains might have become
boring after a while jigsaw remains an
interesting antagonist especially since
technically speaking
he never actually kills anyone sure he
puts people in horrific scenarios but he
always offers at least one logical way
to survive
tobin bell brings a sense of legitimacy
and class to what would have otherwise
been a disposable series of torture
focused horror films
his subtle powerful performance has made
the jigsaw killer one of horror's most
memorable villains
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one